you just flew in nice of you to be here
cuz you flew in from Florida yes I did
you got in like today plane got diverted
last night yeah cuz weather yeah and you
know they don't refund your tickets if
you miss your flight for weather is that
true yeah but don't you worry about that
yeah but I do I do fly a lot here's what
I'm noticing Conan a lot of people are
on edge these days rightfully so but
everybody has got these emotional
support dogs now yes you know it used to
be you see one or two around with the
best used to be very rare very rare but
now every kind of dog a little poodles a
little chihuahuas they have the red vest
on I think these red vests are easier to
get them to medical marijuana cards yeah
yes and and you could fly for free with
your dog if they have the red best
thought right these dogs can barely fill
the vest they're like walking out of it
there they're dragging along you know on
the floor of the airport I saw a an
emotional support hamster the other day
you saw an emotional support hamster
yeah they fight I told my friend so you
should put on a red vest and fly for
free just sit by my feet and be quiet if
I fall over well I would love to see one
of these dogs saddle up next to like a
real bomb sniffing dog at the airport
those dogs are serious oh man those
these things man I wouldn't even mess
with that but what do they think of
these little dogs you know they say
anything what what is that like a
windbreaker again I want is that a
Christmas sweater vest you go no what is
that this this is a 17 pound armored
Kevlar you know bulletproof vest even
dogs have contempt for therapy dogs I do
I know they do I sniff they sniff out
bombs they rest their lives yeah what is
this what do you do for your owner well
you know my owners prone to mood swings
and so forth but you could tell the ones
that are trained at the airport you know
they could pick up dime up off the floor
they could open up the door they can
even predict one there this is the
craziest they make a predict when their
owner is about to have a seizure and
that's true I've heard of that these
dogs that know the owners about to have
a seizure and they know that they call
9-1-1 right away
I've never heard that one before that's
good but no but there's some of the
other dogs that you can tell the other
ones aren't trained you know they bark
they sniff you know they beg for food at
the at the airport restaurant but
sometimes if you see a dog like dry
humping their owners leg mm-hmm not
necessarily about maybe the owners a sex
addict and this dog can predict orgasms
you're sick
the dog is predicting an orgasm maybe
maybe that's all I'm saying
what a great dog to have on a Saturday
night you go bar-hopping should we go in
this part how about this bar this bar
buddy this bar no no no they could
predict orgasm and then it starts when
it starts humping your leg that's that's
good time that's go time Wow dumbest
theory I've heard in a long time I'm
just being honest I am NOT I'm not like
you know what do you call it
comedian yeah I mean I'm just I just
observed that's all sir yeah I'm better
at observing hands I noticed that you
seem obsessed with hands lately
you